[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
ecuador que elige presidente este
domingo en unas elecciones marcadas sin
duda por la pandemia para ello me
acompañan en este estudio
emanuel sinardet responsable del centro
de estudios ecuatorianos de la
universidad parís nantes bienvenida a
manuel buenos días gracias por la
invitación
rafael morán periodista compañero de
rafic que estuvo allí sobre terreno
cubriendo la primera vuelta de estas
elecciones bienvenidos rafael buenos
días carros y bien dúplex el historiador
alexis medina de la universidad house
compte especializado en la historia de
ecuador señor medina buenos días
buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación ecuador decide muchas cosas
entre ellas si recupera el legado del ex
presidente rafael correa lo analizamos
hoy en primera plana
ah
incertidumbre pandemia y muchos
indecisos configuran el escenario en el
que los ecuatorianos van a decidir su
futuro político el izquierdista andrés
araúz y el derechista guillermo lasso
sostienen una pelea codo a codo y quien
gane este domingo deberá enfrentarse a
los estragos de la pandemia con una
caída económica marcada en el país lo
que pasa en ecuador tendrá un eco
probable en otros países de américa
latina que enfrentan procesos
electorales próximamente sin ir más
lejos este domingo está cargado de citas
electorales en los países andinos
también con elecciones departamentales
en bolivia y perú que renueva ejecutivo
y legislativo como marcará la pandemia
estos procesos y sobre todo cómo van a
gestionar la situación económica de la
post pandemia quienes salgan elegidos de
ellos es una pregunta hambre ampliable
en varios casos repasemos antes de ir
con ello algunas portadas que nos deja
la prensa el universo se hace eco de
como las restricciones han afectado a
los candidatos que han tenido que
renunciar a actos masivos en ocho
provincias del país que concentran la
mayor cantidad de electores mercurio se
hacía eco hace unas semanas de como
oficialmente el candidato indígena
pérez quedaba fuera de esta segunda
vuelta después de un recuento
controvertido la hora los candidatos
buscan transformar los likes en votos
ambos candidatos atención a la uci las
obtienen un 20% según este diario de
seguidores falsos en sus redes sociales
bueno el señor aznar de que se juega en
ecuador este domingo exactamente se
juega a un enfrentamiento entre
correístas y anti correístas más que esa
oposición tradicional entre derecha y
la izquierda y de hecho el presidente
elegido tendrá muchas dificultades para
gobernar porque el congreso nacional en
las elecciones de febrero no tiene
mayoría clara lo vamos a volver sobre
esa figura de rafael correct sin duda
planea en la atmósfera de estas
elecciones pero mi compañero rafael
morán estuvo cubriendo para regir la
primera vuelta sobre terreno de estas
elecciones
rafael qué aspectos le llamaron la
atención sobre la realidad de ecuador en
estos momentos de elecciones si hay tres
cosas carlos primero por supuesto las
consecuencias de la pandemia de
coronavirus en una ciudad como guayaquil
los traumas las consecuencias de la
pandemia son visibles palpables cada
quien tiene un familiar que falleció de
kobe no ha tenido cabida 2 la
preocupación por la situación
socioeconómica la caída del ingreso el
desempleo los recortes draconianos en la
función pública han dejado muchas
consecuencias y 13 lo mencionaba emanuel
en la polarización en torno al legado de
rafael correa que ha dejado pues una
fuerte huella en la sociedad ecuatoriana
señor medina varias encuestas han
colocado por delante araúz desde el
final de la primera vuelta vencedor de
un accidente a la primera vuelta pero la
tendencia ha sido recortando en los
últimos días de que puede depender el
triunfo de las o de arauz
bueno en realidad puede depender de
varias cosas
es cierto que el contexto general es
favorable
araos es decir con una pandemia café
asolado al país
tiene más eco un discurso sobre un
estado protector capaz de ofrecer salud
capaz de vacunar capaz de proteger a la
población de los del golpe económico que
representa la pandemia en este caso en
ese contexto
el proyecto que opera la de guillermo
lasso le cuesta más imponerse sin
embargo ahora en estos días hay una
disputa entre la sociedad para
determinar el sable del gobierno
desastroso que ha sido el del en
enfrente se lanzó a usar los corridistas
de haber puesto a lenin moreno en el
play y los correístas analizó y comprado
luego no vamos a ver si mejoramos un
poco la conexión con el señor medina que
se corta por momentos la campaña entra
raúl y lass o ha estado marcada por
ataques arauz incide en las propiedades
e intereses del banquero las o en otros
países las o por su parte
a la sombra del ex presidente correa que
gobernó una década en ecuador y fue
condenado en ausencia ocho años por
corrupción
nosotros vamos a fortalecer insisto la
dolarización pero generando trabajo en
el ecuador no en panamá o en miami donde
usted tiene estos dólares nosotros
queremos impulsar el trabajo productivo
en nuestra patria mira lo que dijo tu
jefe
tu padre político el presidente de la
república no solo el jefe del poder
ejecutivo el jefe de todo el estado
ecuatoriano demostrando claramente que
esa es una frase dictatorial qué opinas
de eso
rafael digo andrés perdón
vemos como la señora es inerte como la
figura de correa planea como decía antes
en qué se diferenciará un el delfín del
mentor del padre de correa es muy
interesante porque en la primera vuelta
y funcionó
arauz realmente insistió en su conexión
hasta su filiación con su mentor
en la primera vuelta a la el inglés con
hologramas incluso si afiches y este
punto fuerte que le permitió llegar a la
segunda vuelta ahora es su punto flojo
es su debilidad porque es fácil hoy en
día para lazo agitar esta sombra de
correa y amenazar a una posibilidad de
transformar si gana el correísmo al
ecuador en una nueva venezuela es decir
una especie se ve se ve más claramente
ese plebiscito sobre el correísmo en una
en una segunda vuelta de uco con ello o
contra ello se ve claramente perdón e
incluso intentó marcar distancias en la
segunda vuelta el candidato araus sin
realmente convencer quizá la pregunta a
la que nos lleve esto es porque persiste
el correísmo en ecuador tanto tiempo
después y tras una condena y una
inhabilitación
por una razón muy sencilla karim cuando
una entrevista a la gente en la calle la
gente modesta en ecuador tiene una
respuesta muy clara y muy sencilla con
araus con rafael correa perdón yo
también joel el traspié me trago en la
lengua en la época de rafael correa les
iba bien económicamente eran los años de
bonanza económica de los precios altos
del petróleo y había también una fuerte
política de inversiones públicas está
pasando ha pasado todo lo contrario con
el mandato de lenin moreno que ha
recortado masivamente los recursos
públicos la administración pública y el
país está sufriendo una crisis muy
fuerte por la caída de los precios de
las materias primas entonces hay este
recuerdo de una edad un poco dorada al
menos dinámica de la economía en la que
mucha gente salió también de la pobreza
lo cual fue todo lo contrario en los
últimos años 3 más de 3 millones de
ecuatorianos cayeron en una situación de
pobreza
y el señor medina también ve esta
especie de elección plebiscitaria sobre
la figura de rafael correa
si es la verdad es que en un principio
parecía que con la primera vuelta había
una voluntad del electorado de superar
el cribaje o ritmo y ante corréis qué es
lo que explica el buen resultado de
otras candidaturas que quedaron en verse
en cuarto lugar pero la configuración de
la segunda vuelta reactiva esta
dicotomía correísmo antiguo ritz el
líder indígena ya coupé de denunció
fraude al quedar marginado del balotaje
por unas décimas claro ahora nos
preguntamos ese porcentaje es el 20 por
ciento a dónde irá
la posición pero difícilmente la
posición de la conaie y pachakutik es
abogar por el voto nulo que presentan
incluso como un voto útil ideológico
señalaremos que pachakutik es el brazo
político del mayor movimiento indígena
ecuador que ahora mismo es segunda
fuerza política si no me equivoco en el
parlamento no exacto y es más
se acaba de crear en el parlamento un
bloque entre pachakutik y la izquierda
democrática y llegan a ser la primera
fuerza en el parlamento entonces este
voto nulo hace difícil cualquier
pronóstico pero sabemos que hay muchas
fracturas y divisiones dentro de la
conaie y de hecho jaime vargas que fue
hasta hace muy poco presidente de la
conaie dijo que votaría por araus cuando
la candidata la ex candidata para
vicepresidenta con la q pérez en la
primera vuelta dijo que ella votaría por
lazo entonces hoy en día en vísperas de
las elecciones resulta todavía muy
difícil saber a ciencia cierta si van a
respetar esa consigna de voto nulo o si
van a decidirse por uno u otro de los
candidatos es decir finalmente ese 20
por ciento de votos de pérez y esa bolsa
de indecisos hacen que al final allí hay
un porcentaje de votos importantes que
puedan decidir
segunda vuelta y que no estén claros sí
porque además uno de los temas centrales
de la campaña de ya q pérez fue la
protección del medio ambiente y este
tema estaba prácticamente ausente de la
campaña de guillermo lasso y no es el
tema central en el programa the andrew
zarautz aunque sí tiene un discurso
sobre la justicia ecológica y ecológica
en la segunda vuelta precisamente
durante la campaña lazo lanzó mensajes
hacia los electores dijo cooper es
diciendo que también el reconociendo que
no es el tema central de su campaña la
protección del medio ambiente pero que
él sí tiene un acercamiento con estos
temas pero realmente todo está abierto y
no queda claro para nada
a quién van a ir estos votos de masivos
e inesperados de ya cooper es el señor
medina economía antes hablamos con
rafael de algunos de esos retos economía
desempleo pobreza creciente arrastrada
por la situación de pandemia cuál de
todos es el reto más acuciante que
tendrá el próximo presidente de ecuador
el primero es el proceso de vacunación
incluso desde un punto de vista
económico no se puede reabrir la
economía si no estaba con nada la
población y el ecuador está muy atrasado
en proceso de donación apenas trap ha
colgado un poco más de presión mil
personas han recibido al menos una dosis
y luego sin más generalmente está la
crisis económica y la situación del
empleo es decir hoy la mayoría de la
población económicamente activa está en
desempleo o subempleo si ha habido una
precarización y un cimiento general la
acción
como consecuencia económica ya venía
desde altas de línea pero que la
potencia ha procesado tendrá mucho
pasado en unos instantes vamos a
profundizar en esos problemas económicos
de ecuador será a la vuelta de esta
breve pausa
sarajevo managua balín ciudades que como
tantas otras han sufrido la guerra el
hambre la dictadura o catástrofes
naturales fukushima
gross y la habana france24 vuelve a las
regiones que marcaron la actualidad
internacional sus habitantes cuentan su
nueva vida sus esperanzas y su lucha
para superar un pasado traumático
un boleto de vuelta una serie inédita de
reportajes en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
compañeros de equipo
y también de la liberté égalité actual y
pti
y no vamos en primera plan esta semana
con el foco en las elecciones de ecuador
como ejemplo de lo que puede ir pasando
en otros países de la región con emanuel
sin arder responsable del centro de
estudios ecuatorianos de la universidad
paris lanter mi compañera rafael morán
que estuvo cubriendo la primera vuelta
de las elecciones allí sobre terreno y
en dúplex de la historiadora alexis
medina de la universidad franz comp
emanuel el fm y pronostica una caída
para la economía ecuatoriana que lleva
al 11 por ciento en que se puede bueno
la gestión va a ser tremenda para el
próximo presidente de ecuador pero quizá
la pregunta sea en qué se va a
diferenciar aunque se podría diferenciar
la gestión de la crisis de la salida de
la post pandemia si la hace arauz o si
la hace las ahí sí tenemos una neta
diferencia entre una propuesta de
izquierda y una propuesta de una derecha
más bien tradicional y clásica el lazo
se presenta como un liberal y quiere
fomentar el crecimiento y el empleo en
base a inversiones extranjeras
liberalización de la economía quiere
favorecer el emprendimiento
esto recuerda una serie de orientaciones
de tipo neoliberal a la inversa el lazo
perdón arau se insiste en un
protagonismo del estado en la economía
con un fortalecimiento del sector
público como actor y motor del
desarrollo en eso sí está recordando
ciertas orientaciones las obras públicas
las infraestructuras que han sido una
faceta del éxito visible del correísmo
el aumento de la pobreza acrecentada por
la crisis que va a dejar la pandemia sin
duda un reto fundamental
rafael usted que estuvo sobre terreno
como viste esta situación porque la
informalidad afecta a casi la mitad de
los empleos si es realmente notable en
primero porque hay un toque de queda lo
había y sigue siendo incluso con medidas
más estrictas con esta segunda ola que
está viviendo el país hospitales
rebasados realmente public tanto
públicos como privados
entonces esto hace que haya menos
actividad incluso en la calle y mucho
crecimiento de la de la informalidad
la gente obviamente que ha perdido su
empleo gente del sector público una
reducción drástica del turismo el centro
de quito por ejemplo está completamente
apagado de noche centro muy activo y
tradicionalmente bastante turístico
entonces si se nota realmente que la
gente sufre y padece es de la crisis
económica un tercio de la población está
en el umbral de la pobreza y gana menos
de 84 dólares al mes señor medina cada
campaña electoral activa la discusión
clásica en ecuador sobre los beneficios
o problemas de la dolarización de la
economía dolarizada es una garantía de
estabilidad o es un lastre para el
crecimiento
bueno en realidad cuando se adoptó la
dolarización fue una decisión muy
polémica pero hoy en día hay un consenso
en torno a la dolarización ningún
candidato puede darse el lujo hoy en día
de anunciar la desconectar la economía o
sea un suicidio político y tanto aráoz
brazo se presentan cada uno candidato
más a tejer la dolarización que hoy día
es visto como la base de la estabilidad
monetaria porque puso fin a una espiral
de hiperinflación que vivió el país en
estos años no en que a pesar de todos
los problemas que representa este
sistema no para empezar simplemente el
país
no es capaz en una política monetaria
pro pero globalmente este consenso en
torno a mantener la dolarización manuel
crea un problema para el ecuador en
cuanto a la dolarización es uno de los
efectos negativos fue un efecto de
desindustrialización es decir que
y la dolarización hace más interesante
importar que fabricar en el mismo país
ahora bien la industrialización
significa también la creación de empleo
y eso hace todavía más difícil las
propuestas de ambos candidatos que basan
mucho de su programa electoral en la
reactivación del crecimiento y del
empleo de hecho ecuador sigue siendo un
país que vive de la exportación de
materias primas el hasta ahora
presidente ni moreno renegoció un
préstamo con el fmi por valor de 7.400
millones de dólares
el nuevo prescinde tendrá tres años de
gracia en el pago de intereses pero
tendrá que encontrar nuevas fuentes de
financiación es un poco la clave que han
propuesto los candidatos en este sentido
entonces
[Música]
con las fuentes de recursos posibles en
el caso de árabes contempla una reforma
tributaria es decir que se contempla la
posibilidad de encontrar en el mismo
país parte de los recursos necesarios
para estas ambiciones económicas por
otro lado el lazo insiste en la
necesidad de crear un clima de confianza
con los inversionistas extranjeros para
atraer a estos capitales hay una
posibilidad que acaba de surgir con una
firma en enero pasado es la firma de un
acuerdo marco para obtener unas ayudas
con una nueva entidad creada por trump
se llama dfc y la idea detrás era
contrarrestar la influencia china en
américa latina y sobre todo en el
ecuador a raíz de las orientaciones de
correa y entonces ahí la promesa de una
serie de ayudas financieras
no se sabe si las hojas mantendrán esta
línea creada por este acuerdo estamos
hablando de ecuador pero quizás vamos a
hacer en un momento un poco de zuma al
resto de la región las elecciones que se
celebran en los países andinos este fin
de semana este domingo también en perú
en bolivia quizá puedan tener unos nexos
en común vamos a explorar los señor
medina y así podemos hablar de algún
nexo en común entre entre los países de
la región elecciones marcadas por la
pandemia un clima de desafección
política notable y no sé si un giro a la
izquierda general en la región que le
parece sí bueno por supuesto que la
pandemia marca la agenda electoral en
américa latina no es el caso en ecuador
el ecuador que fue un país profundamente
afectado por la pandemia pero también en
libia donde lo que es una de las cosas
que estuvieron en juego en las
elecciones presidenciales del año pasado
era también la gestión de la pandemia
parte de james
entonces la pandemia
de las elecciones
y ahora podemos ver un giro general
hacia la izquierda en américa latina me
parece que no completamente si los otros
periodistas han vuelto al poder o se ha
unido en cientos en los últimos años
tim a méxico tenemos un problema para
escuchar correctamente al señor medina
no sé si quiera aportar algo más sobre
este giro que no acababa de ver nos
hemos quedado con la idea de lo que
decía señor medida que no podíamos
titular tan hace un giro al himno del
américa latina en cambio un giro me
parece hacia una visión mucho más
progresista de lo que debe ser la
política y la manera como hacer política
me voy a explicar me parece que los
movimientos sociales del otoño del año
19 mostraron una demanda en general
por algo que llamamos el care que es la
atención a los demás no significa
solamente el cuidado médico desde luego
con la situación de pandemia actual
significa también una atención una
benevolencia que las autoridades
escuchen las demandas las tomen en
consideración y me parece por ejemplo
del caso del ecuador pero también en el
perú los que van a ser elegidos son los
que van a poder compaginar la
expectativa económica con esa
expectativa del que no me quiero sacar
saltar un tema antes de determinar se
trata de una pandemia que han sufrido
aún más las mujeres en países con tanta
temporalidad como la región y donde
ellas deben ocuparse de los cuidados se
ha hablado de alguna mínima perspectiva
de género en esta campaña
rafael hoy tarde muy tarde es decir el
día de los derechos del día
internacional de los derechos de la
mujer el 8 de marzo ambos candidatos
guillermo lasso y andrés araus firmaron
compromisos
a favor de los del respeto y la
promoción de los derechos de las mujeres
pero realmente el lazo es un candidato
muy conservador pertenece a esta
organización ultraconservadora opusdei
católica no es un tema central para él
está en contra del aborto de la del
derecho al aborto está muy limitado
prácticamente prohibido en el ecuador y
por su parte andrés araus ha evitado
tocar el tema dice que respalda la
conquista de los derechos de las mujeres
y que los respaldos respaldar a las
respaldarán si llega al poder pero
tampoco ha propuesto poner sobre la mesa
en la legalización del aborto que hay
que recordar lo recomiendan es algo que
recomiendan los organismos
internacionales para poner fin limitar
frenar y evitar los embarazos
adolescentes las muertes prematuras de
mujeres embarazadas la situación de las
mujeres en ecuador es de extrema
vulneración de derechos en el 2020 172
adolescentes murieron en el momento del
parto cada 13 minutos una mujer decide
abortar y 3.000 niñas menores de 14 años
son violadas
y embarazadas cada año ante esta
realidad los candidatos que respuesta a
la de manuel una respuesta como dijiste
muy limitada en realidad incluso esa
apertura a temas de género aparece
efectivamente en marzo y dentro de lo
que puede ser considerado como una
estrategia electoral es decir que viendo
que el que ganará será la persona capaz
de captar los votos progresistas de ella
cooper es en la primera vuelta y de
javier hervás de la izquierda
democrática también en esta primera
vuelta pues ahí comenzaron a abrir sus
programas a temas ambientales y a temas
de género pero por ejemplo no hay una
visión clara y se limitan mucho a
declaraciones que dicen luchar contra
las desigualdades estructurales entonces
por ejemplo lazo prometió la igualdad de
salario pero no toca el tema de los
derechos
y vinculados con la sexualidad o la
salud sexual
el candidato a rauch por su parte
declaró que crearía una secretaría de la
mujer para luchar contra las violencias
domésticas pero efectivamente se ampara
a la constitución para evitar tocar el
tema de nuevo de la despenalización del
aborto que es una demanda expresada por
numerosos movimientos feministas en el
ecuador
incluso moderados de hecho fue una de
las sorpresas de la de la primera vuelta
porque el candidato oria q pérez fue uno
de los pocos que abiertamente propuso y
puso sobre la mesa del debate sobre la
despenalización del aborto los otros
candidatos no hablaron de eso entonces
como bien dice lo dice manuel hubo una
especie de intento de captación de
marketing político de verde en la
segunda vuelta decir a ver vamos a
hacerla un poco a retomar esas
propuestas propuestas de manera muy
ambigua
y bueno tan claro como ya q pérez para
captar sus votos me quedo sin tiempo ha
sido muy interesante compartir este
programa esta edición sobre ecuador con
ustedes emanuel citar de mi compañero
rafael morán y en dúplex alexis medina
desde la universidad franz compre ya
todos ustedes hasta la próxima semana
quien en primera plana gracias
[Música]